y en directo ahora vamos hasta Caracas
donde se reunieron hoy el presidente
Nicolás maduro y su homólogo colombiano
Gustavo Petro se trata del primer
encuentro entre presidentes de estos dos
países en seis años ambos mandatarios
acordaron seguir trabajando en diversos
temas como la migración y la seguridad
binacional para la ampliación de esta
noticia saludamos en la capital
venezolana a nuestra corresponsal
Daniela Zambrano Daniela Muy buenas
noches cuéntenos Que acordaron los
mandatarios
Nicolás Maduro calificó esta reunión
como fructífera intensa y extensa entre
los acuerdos está la reincorporación de
Venezuela la comunidad andina de
Naciones y se exhortaban los países
miembros permitir el ingreso nuevamente
de Venezuela un punto importante la
respuesta que dio Nicolás Maduro a la
propuesta del presidente Gustavo Petro
de que Venezuela vuelva al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos dijo
que había sido bastante receptivo No
negó esta posibilidad fue la respuesta
que dio Nicolás Maduro también se habló
sobre dar un mejor trato a los migrantes
y hacía referencia al presidente Gustavo
Petro a lo ocurrido en la frontera con
Estados Unidos y que eventualmente sería
en las próximas semanas no dio fecha
realmente un encuentro entre empresarios
colombianos y venezolanos en Cartagena
también se habló de una eventual
apertura total de la frontera Colombo
venezolana el presidente Gustavo Petro
en que esta actualmente está gobernada
por mafias eso fueron los principales
temas que abordaron ambos mandatarios en
esta reunión que duró cerca de tres
horas de forma privada y que
posteriormente luego se dio una
declaración conjunta en la que no se
permitió preguntas por parte de los
medios de comunicación Daniel os he
mencionado hace un momento la eventual
reincorporación de Venezuela al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos
Porque es importante
organizaciones no gubernamentales
Defensores de Derechos Humanos
consideran que es positivo que Venezuela
pueda reincorporarse al sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos Esto
tomando en cuenta que no significa que
el régimen de Nicolás maduro vaya a
acatar las decisiones de este organismo
Pues en años anteriores cuando
pertenecía Pues tampoco se hacía caso
omiso de las recomendaciones que hacía
este organismo sin embargo si es
importante para las víctimas para que
tengan una institución donde poder
denunciar las violaciones a derechos
humanos y se lleva un registro formal de
estos casos que posteriormente puedan
ser presentados ante organismos como la
Corte Penal Internacional y la
organización de Naciones Unidas
importante destacar que este mismo
martes el propio fiscal de la Corte
Penal Internacional karincamp dijo que
se aprobaba continuar con la
investigación sobre crímenes de lesa
humanidad que se hayan cometidos que se
hayan cometido en Venezuela por por
tanto por el presidente Nicolás Maduro
no podía negar de forma pública no
querer reincorporarse al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos
cuando tiene esta investigación en curso
es la opinión de algunas organizaciones
no gubernamentales